back in season one it was a huge meme to
pick on armin because
well he was a wimp i'm ashamed to say
that even i threw around armin jokes
from time to time but as the series has
progressed
without even myself consciously noticing
he became
easily my favorite character in the
whole series
and today i've tried to encompass why
that is why the trials and emotional
growth that armin has experienced
make him not just my favorite character
but an incredible character overall
i think the idea that armin was a wimp
in the first season is slightly
exaggerated
if anything i think that armin was or at
least started out as the very opposite
he was branded as a heretic because he
wasn't afraid to express
his desires to escape the walls the bird
cage that was closing them all in
and simply because he didn't have the
physical capacity to defend himself from
people who didn't like that idea he was
commonly branded as
lame this idea perpetuated through
all of season 1 with aaron having to
save him from that titan
because he didn't contribute much to the
survey corps at this point in the story
after all as cadets what mattered was
one simple thing
whether you could kill a titan whether
you could survive
and that embodies what all of attack on
titan was at the very beginning but as
the story rapidly began to expand in
season 2 and 3
we likewise saw armin flourish with the
show's growing ideas
which speaks volumes about how deep his
character is
armin has never really been a wimp but
rather an outspoken person who has been
pushed into thinking his ideas were
worthless
but let's skip to season 3 where i think
that we discover who armin really is
behind the lack of self-confidence and
weak frame
armin never thought his life to be
valuable when aaron saved him from the
titan in season 1
you could argue that this made armin
realize his value to his friends
but if anything i think it reaffirmed
what he himself believed
not just that he wasn't yet equal to
eren and mikasa
but that he had to change himself for
the better he wanted to reach a point
where if this situation were to happen
again
he could sacrifice himself feeling like
he was worth it knowing that he'd
changed
and we get this chance in season 3 part
2 in the battle for shigan china
armin's plan to take down bird holt
required him to sacrifice his own life
to take him down
armin was indebted to aaron for as long
as he could remember
ever since aaron had to rescue him from
back alleys from bullies
and especially ever since aaron
sacrificed himself to rescue armin from
the titan in season one
and even if aaron survived that the
action itself had repercussions and
thematic purpose
beating bertholdt was armin's moment it
was meant to be
to show that his mind had become a
valuable asset that he could think of
his plan
and that he'd grown past the idea that
his body was worthless
and instead used it as a strength
throwing it away to secure the colossal
titan
but most of all it was his way to free
himself of his debt to aaron
a big part of armin's personality was
his lack of confidence
much of which stemmed from being
overshadowed by aaron and mikasa
it was made clear from the beginning
that he wanted to someday think of
himself
as their equal and this is where he did
it to repay aaron for saving his life so
long ago
he gave his life once again for him it's
a zero-sum game
armin dies knowing that he has finally
become capable of saving his friends
instead of it always just being the
other way around is free from their
shadows that have kept his
self-confidence hidden
but of course they lose him as a result
they lose someone who has finally come
into understanding who he is
and his value to everyone in the survey
core
until the injection comes into play
and i talked about the reasons armin was
chosen over heroin a lot in my other
video so check that out if you haven't
already
and i won't be laboring too much over
the specifics here
but it gave armin essentially a restart
button
to begin anew as a completely
independent version of who he once was
but of course there's a cost we know
from attack on titan that arguably the
biggest cost
of all of this is the cost of life and
more specifically as we get further into
the show how this can be caused by one's
loss of humanity
just as aaron began a new era in his
life after being brought back from the
dead
i guess after being eaten by the titan
revealing to himself
and everyone that he's a titan shifter
the same happens to armin here
he's alive once again but burdened with
so much more
the memories of all those dead holders
before him he can't escape
it his very first memory upon coming
back to life
it was burt holt's crying it's the fate
of a titan shifter that reiner forebodes
in season four
and he's gone from being this character
who had no value for his own life
to someone who can essentially not die
but is forced to remember the taken
lives before him
and he's also left with the guilt the
incredible burden
on his shoulders of living up to erwin's
legacy the self-confidence that he
gained by sacrificing himself
by feeling like he was worth it is
almost relinquished
by having to live up to the expectations
of the colossal titan of irwin's
replacement
and even though he is himself a new man
someone completely different from irwin
there's always going to be that part of
himself that part of armin who thinks
that he's still just his replacement
that he is nothing compared to what
erwin could have been
something that he's always had since he
was a child
in essence what i'm trying to say is
that armin is the embodiment of how no
one
can really be free he was tied down by
society's criticism
and his own as a child but escaped that
by maturing and finding self-worth in
some kind of way
he felt like he wasn't enough but
redeemed himself through the battle of
shiguncina
and he's finally escaped the walls he's
seen the sea
as has always been his dream only to be
met
by enemies across it it never
ends but armin also never stops
and that's what's awesome about his
character that he truly never stops
trying to improve himself
and find a solution to whatever comes
his way
he knows better than anyone the lack of
self-confidence he has
the feeling that he must always live up
to someone else's expectations
and he always pushes on despite that and
tries to change himself for the better
so yeah i mean that's why i love armin
he's a great character
his role in the series is absolutely
invaluable
and in season 4 and further on we're
seeing how he's actually becoming this
kind of rival figure to aaron
this person who was once his friend and
his brother almost
i mean armin will certainly have one of
the most pivotal roles in the finale of
the series and i think this is where his
story will come full circle
perhaps he'll finally break free of
everything that's shackling him down
maybe he can finally become
free but you know
we'll see as always this has been the
anime culture corner i hope you enjoyed
the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
[Music]
analyses
you